Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological well-being practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the client. clinical psychology doctorate, but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot.
你好，我叫贝丝，是一名来自纽卡斯尔的心理健康从业者。我非常感谢《临床心理学家集体》一书的撰稿人。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，也很高兴能深入了解人们在申请博士学位之前所拥有的各种背景和经历。了解申请过程中可能遇到的障碍以及我如何尝试克服这些障碍，真的非常有趣。我曾经开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够优秀去申请临床心理学博士学位，但这本书确实给了我所需要的自信，让我决定试一试。
So the biggest thank you ever. Most therapy strives to understand what's wrong with you, but what if you aren't the problem at all? Today I'm sitting down with three fellow clinical psychologists to explore narrative therapy. It's an approach that does something quite different instead of diagnosing or fixing. It helps people separate themselves from the problem and instead to view their lives and as a story that can be rewritten. We talk about grief, dementia, identity,
所以，这是我最诚挚的感谢。大多数疗法致力于了解你出了什么问题，但如果你根本就不是问题所在呢？今天，我与三位临床心理学家同行坐在一起，探讨叙事疗法。这是一种非常不同的方法，它不是诊断或修复，而是帮助人们将自己与问题分离开来，并将他们的生活视为一个可以重写的故事。我们谈论悲伤、痴呆、身份，
and even a sneaky poo. Yes, a sneaky poo. And we're also talking about why language in therapy might just matter more than you think. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to psychology, actually. We've got a lovely episode today and we're joined by three guests.
甚至还有“鬼祟便便”。是的，就是“鬼祟便便”。我们还要讨论为什么治疗中的语言可能比你想象的更重要。希望你觉得这很有用。你好，欢迎来到“心理学，其实是这样”。我们今天有一期很棒的节目，有三位嘉宾加入。
It's really lovely to have you here. We're talking about narrative therapy, And before we kind of share who our guests are, I think it can be really helpful to define our terms. Rosalind, could you tell us what narrative therapy is? Yeah, I can certainly give that a go, Marianne. Although one of the things about narrative therapy is the people who initially developed it,
很高兴你们能来。我们正在谈论叙事疗法，在介绍我们的嘉宾之前，我认为定义一下我们的术语会很有帮助。罗莎琳，你能告诉我们什么是叙事疗法吗？好的，玛丽安，我当然可以试一试。尽管关于叙事疗法的一点是，最初开发它的人，
which was Michael White and David Epston back in the 80s, based in Australia and New Zealand, as they were very concerned about trying to pin it down or define it too tightly, because they had this idea that we should have a spirit of adventure to which lots of people can contribute, and so the ideas can evolve and be organic. But I'll give it a go at trying to capture what it is in essence. So it comes out of the systemic therapies that is postmodern an approach.
也就是80年代在澳大利亚和新西兰的迈克尔·怀特和大卫·爱普斯顿，他们非常担心将其固定或定义得太死板，因为他们认为我们应该保持一种冒险精神，让许多人都能做出贡献，这样这些想法才能不断演变和有机发展。但我会试着从本质上捕捉它是什么。它源于系统疗法，是一种后现代方法。
So that means that Michael White, David Epston, were concerned about an idea of not bringing your own assumptions and your own ideas of what's right or how we should be as people, into therapy, but to be listening very carefully and centering the person we're working with and their expertise. So we put to one side our own, we try to avoid getting into hypothesizing or formulating, which I know is very different from other psychological therapies. But instead of drawing on a whole range of critical theories from coming from psychology and developmental psychology and social psychology and systemic psychotherapy, but also from anthropology, sociology, philosophy, which makes it very kind of lively and interesting approach.
这意味着迈克尔·怀特和大卫·爱普斯顿担心不要把自己的假设和关于什么是对的、或者我们作为人应该是什么样的想法带入治疗中，而是要非常仔细地倾听，并以我们合作的人及其专业知识为中心。所以我们把自己的想法放在一边，尽量避免陷入假设或公式化，我知道这与其他心理疗法非常不同。但我们不是借鉴心理学、发展心理学、社会心理学和系统心理治疗中的一系列批判理论，而是借鉴人类学、社会学、哲学，这使得它成为一种非常生动和有趣的方法。
But what we're trying to do when we're listening to the person is to understand the stories that have developed about them and their lives in the context they're in, so from their family and their community and the stories that they might have internalized themselves. And to be listening out to the ones that seem to be helpful to them and ones that may be less helpful. So quite often people arrive with very problem-saturated stories, which have almost become them or how they see themselves and how other people defined them. So one of the first things we'd be doing
但当我们倾听当事人时，我们试图理解在他们所处的环境中，关于他们及其生活所形成的故事，也就是来自他们的家庭、社区以及他们自己可能内化了的故事。我们要倾听那些对他们有帮助的故事，以及那些可能不太有帮助的故事。所以人们往往带着充满问题的叙事而来，这些叙事几乎成了他们本身，或者成了他们如何看待自己以及他人如何定义他们的方式。所以我们做的第一件事
is to try and help the person separate from that. So we use language of externalising the problem and we're very much using their words for that. And then we might be listening very carefully to alternative, more helpful stories. They're closer to what that person's preferences or hopes for their life might be. And we're trying to draw those out
就是尝试帮助当事人与这些叙事分离开来。我们使用“外化问题”的语言，并且非常多地使用他们自己的词汇。然后，我们可能会非常仔细地倾听那些替代性的、更有帮助的故事。它们更接近那个人对生活的偏好或希望。我们试图引出这些故事，
and thicken those stories and make them more accessible than those problems, saturated ones. And there's lots of ideas we use in doing that, which pay attention to things like social discourses, so those are like those prescriptions in the world about how one should be, whether that's how you should look as a young man or how you should be as a mother or what aging well looks like. And we help try and make those visible for people so they can make their own choices about that.
并充实这些故事，使它们比那些充满问题的叙事更容易被获取。我们在这样做时会使用许多想法，这些想法关注社会话语，比如世界上关于一个人应该如何表现的规定，无论是作为一个年轻人你应该看起来什么样，还是作为一个母亲你应该如何表现，或者老龄化得好是什么样子。我们帮助人们使这些规定变得可见，这样他们就可以对此做出自己的选择。
very much working with people in their social context. The narrative therapy has some really interesting practices about working with groups of people and community groups, not just with individuals and families. And it's been developed and evolved throughout, you know, across the globe, which makes it a really interesting perspective cross-culturally. It tries to move away from more traditional Western ideas of the self, for example,
我们非常注重在人们的社会背景下与他们合作。叙事疗法在与人群和社区团体合作方面有一些非常有趣的实践，不仅仅是针对个人和家庭。它在全球范围内得到发展和演变，这使得它在跨文化视角下非常有趣。它试图摆脱更传统的西方自我观念，例如，
and be very, and be culturally sensitive to the particular ways of thinking that the person you're working with, might have and to understand them. So that's it. I think in a bit of a nutshell, I hope that makes sense. Hopefully as we go along some of the other things we share with you will help illustrate some of those ideas. It sounded it was a great nutshell, Rosalind. Now we're speaking with you before we go on to have a quick chat with Elizabeth and Polly to find out who they are. Could you tell us a little bit about yourself, Rossell, how you got into narrative therapy and what your core profession is? Yes, of course. Yes. So I work as a clinical
并对当事人可能拥有的特定思维方式保持文化敏感，并去理解他们。所以，简而言之就是这样，希望这说得通。希望随着我们的深入，我们分享的其他一些事情将有助于阐明其中的一些想法。听起来这是一个很棒的总结，罗莎琳。现在，在我们继续与伊丽莎白和波莉简短交谈以了解她们是谁之前，你能告诉我们一点关于你自己的情况吗，罗斯，你是如何接触到叙事疗法的，你的核心职业是什么？好的，当然。是的。我是一名临床
psychologist. I work with older people and in particular people living with dementia. But to me, so when I did my clinical training, I was very interested in community in critical psychology and I struggled to find a therapeutic model that I felt paid sufficient attention to some of those ideas that discussed in critical psychology. And when I came across narrative therapy, I just went to a workshop, one of Michael White's workshops in London about 20 years ago. And it completely it was like an epiphany for me. I thought, oh, this is what works. This is how I can bring my psychology and think therapeutically about people in ways that praise proper attention to those, all those social and political and cultural factors that we understand, interact, you know,
心理学家。我与老年人合作，特别是患有痴呆症的人。但对我来说，当我进行临床培训时，我对社区和批判心理学非常感兴趣，我努力寻找一种我认为能充分关注批判心理学中讨论的那些想法的治疗模式。当我接触到叙事疗法时，我参加了大约20年前在伦敦举办的迈克尔·怀特的工作坊。这对我来说完全是一个顿悟。我想，哦，这就是有效的方法。这就是我如何能够运用我的心理学，并以一种对那些我们理解的、导致人们痛苦的社会、政治和文化因素给予适当关注的方式，来从治疗的角度思考人们。所以这就是我进入这个领域的方式。然后多年来，当我第一次，我后来去参加了一些叙事疗法培训，我在那里很早就遇到了伊丽莎白，我们俩是当时仅有的与老年人合作的人，实际上我们一路上只遇到过几个像波莉这样的人，所以我们当时的希望是，我们如何把这些想法传播出去？因为叙事疗法在其他服务用户群体中已经相当成熟，但在老年人中却不是这样，我们在叙事疗法中没有听到太多关于老年人的信息，或者在老年人的世界里也没有听到太多关于叙事疗法的信息，所以这对我们来说正在获得动力，我们与其他老年心理学家和其他类型的从业者聚集在一起，
in terms of contributing to people's distress. So that was my way into it. And then over the years, when I first, I then went into doing some narrative therapy training where I met Elizabeth very early on and the two of us were the only people working with older people at the time and actually we've only met a few others like polly along the way and so the hope for us was actually how do we get these ideas out there because narrative therapy is not quite established with other service user groups but not so much of older people and we weren't hearing much about older people in narrative therapy or about narrative therapy in the world of older people so that then is gaining momentum for us in terms of coming together with other older adult psychologists and other types of practitioners
试图发展其中的一些想法。非常感谢。你可能会感到惊讶，我第一次听说叙事疗法是在我为CAMS（儿童和青少年心理健康服务）工作时，那里有很多系统性的想法，这很棒。这就是我开始了解它并开始实践其中一些内容的地方。是朱迪·萨顿，她过去常做很多关于叙事疗法的工作。
to try and develop some of these ideas. Thank you so much. It might surprise you that I first heard of narrative therapy when I was working in a CAMS service with lots of systemic ideas in it, and it was lovely. And that's kind of where I started learning about it and starting to kind of practice some of that. It was Judy Sutton who used to do lots of work around narrative therapy.
所以这不仅仅是老年人，我喜欢一路上收集临床医生的过程。不，不，不。绝对不是。不，它在儿童工作中非常成熟。实际上，我是在一个儿童实习中接触到它的，用的是“鬼祟便便”，这就是，但我不知道，我知道“鬼祟便便”，但我不知道它处于叙事实践的背景下或其理论根源中。所以那是后来我的一个发现。但你说得对，它在儿童服务中被广泛使用，在那里它有很好的，是的。太棒了。我觉得我们不能，“鬼祟便便”确实听起来很耳熟，但我觉得我们不能给出一个像“鬼祟便便”这样的术语而不简要描述它是什么。你能告诉我们什么是“鬼祟便便”吗，罗莎琳？哦天哪，我大约30年前在和这个一起工作时做过这个。
So it's not just an older adult, I love the only collecting clinicians along the way. No, no, no. Absolutely not. No, it's very well established in children's work. And I had come across it, actually, on a child placement, using sneaky poo, which is where, but I didn't know, I knew sneaky poo, but I didn't know that that's sat in the context of narrative practice or the theoretical roots of that. So that was a discovery I made later. But no, you're right. It's very well used in children's services where it has a good, yeah. Amazing. I feel like we can't, sneaky poo does ring a bell, but I feel like we can't give a term like sneaky poo and they're not. not briefly describe what it is. Could you tell us what sneaky poo is, Rosalie? Oh God, I've done this about 30 years ago when I was working with this.
所以“鬼祟便便”是迈克尔·怀特为患有大便失禁的儿童找到的一种方法，即憋住大便然后发生事故，所以我提到的外化想法很大程度上就是这个。所以大便会是，那就是“鬼祟便便”。“鬼祟便便”进来了并导致了这个问题。所以你会和孩子及其家人一起工作，
So sneaky poo was an approach you found by Michael White for children with and caprices, so withholding feces and then would have accidents, so that idea of externalising I mentioned was very much this. So the poo would be, that's sneaky poo. Sneaky poo has got in and caused this problem. So you'd work with a child and their family
思考“鬼祟便便”看起来是什么样子的。这是一本带有“鬼祟便便”图片的小册子。你会思考帮助“鬼祟便便”的事情，以及作为孩子你可以做些什么来打败“鬼祟便便”。所以这是非常经典的叙事实践，也是人们可能熟悉的一个想法。但外面有很多这样可爱的想法，
around thinking about what sneaky poo looks. It's a little booklet with pictures of sneaky poo. And you think the things that help sneaky poo and the things which you can do as a child to kind of beat sneaky poo. And so that's very classic kind of narrative practice and an idea of people might be familiar with. But there's lots of these lovely ideas out there
人们不一定知道，比如我们稍后会谈到的“生命之树”，但那也是一个叙事想法，人们可能孤立地知道它，但不一定是在那个更广泛的背景下。非常感谢。我喜欢这个解释。对我来说，重温“鬼祟便便”的记忆真的很美好。
that people don't necessarily, like Tree of Life, we'll talk about later, but that's also a narrative idea that sits with the people might know in isolation, but not necessarily been in that whole wider context. Thank you so much. I love that explanation. It was really nice to go back down memory lane for me
伊丽莎白，你能告诉我们一点关于你自己的情况以及你是如何接触到叙事疗法的吗？好的，玛丽安，我是一名临床心理学家，在痴呆症和心理健康服务领域与老年人合作。几年前，我被叙事疗法深深吸引，听迈克尔·怀特谈论他与残疾人合作的工作，
with Sneaky Pooh. Elizabeth, could you tell us a little bit about yourself and how you got into narrative therapy? So yes, Mary Ann, I'm a clinical psychologist working with older people across both dementia and mental health services. I got really attracted to narrative therapy some years ago. hearing Michael White talk about his work with people with learning disabilities,
特别是在叙事疗法如何适应人们的认知能力方面，以及作为治疗师，我们有责任适应语言和概念，以人们能够参与的方式，那种脚手架。我真的被这一点吸引了，因为我当时正在与一些患有各种认知障碍或在心理健康困难的同时患有痴呆症的老年人合作。其中一些人，都来自没有读写能力去填写关于他们想法的图表的背景，
particularly around the way that narrative therapy can adapt to people's cognitive abilities, and that the onus is on us as therapists to adapt to the language, to the concepts in ways that people can kind of take part, that kind of scaffolding. And that really, it was really drawn to that because I was working with a number of older people, who had various different cognitive impairments or had dementia alongside mental health difficulties. And some of the, all came from backgrounds where they didn't have the literacy skills to fill in kind of charts about their thoughts,
他们不会写字。所以我真的发现叙事疗法是一种我们可以利用人们的能力而不是纠结于他们不能做什么的方法。它还为你提供了处理人们所处背景的途径、框架和技能。例如，许多老年人既内化了年龄歧视，又生活在一个非常年龄歧视的社会中。
they couldn't write. And so I really found narrative therapy was a way that we could work with people's abilities rather than get caught up in what they couldn't do. It also gives you ways and frameworks and skills for working with the context that people are presenting in. So, for example, a lot of older people have both internalised and are living in a very ageist society.
这种叙事疗法为我们提供了思考这些话语以及它们如何与某人正在经历的问题相互作用的方法。我非常被将人与问题分离开来所吸引。这非常符合我的价值观。你知道，人们因为各种原因而产生问题，我们可以从他们生活中正在发生的事情，以及社会中正在发生的事情来思考这些问题。这真的引起了共鸣，并且在我与老年人的工作中显得非常相关，
And this narrative therapy gives us ways for thinking about those discourses and how they interact with the problem that somebody's experiencing. And I was very attracted to separating the person from the problem. That fits very much with my values. You know, people have problems for all kinds of reasons. and we can think about them both kind of within what's going on in their lives, but also kind of what's going on in society as well. And that really resonated and seemed really relevant to my working with older people,
这就是为什么我一直与罗莎琳保持联系，我们在培训课程上相遇，并继续保持这些联系。太棒了。非常感谢，伊丽莎白。是的，这真的很强大，不是吗？将一个人与一个问题外化的想法。我认为特别是当我们有家庭时，他们与此如此紧密相连并受到影响。所以很明显，如厕是儿童和年轻人的一大问题。但当然，随着人们年龄的增长，认知能力的变化
which is why I've kind of kept connected with Roslyn when we met on a training course and carried on those links. Amazing. Thank you so much, Elizabeth. Yeah, it is really powerful, isn't it, the idea of externalising a person from a problem. And I think especially when we've got families, where they are so connected and affected by this. So obviously toileting is a big one with children and young people. But of course, as people age, changes in cognition
以及人们是否开始出现痴呆症的迹象，这确实对家庭以及当事人本身都有影响。所以那种帮助人们将痴呆症或认知变化视为独立事物的想法确实可以非常强大且重要。这让我想起当我还是格雷厄姆·斯托克斯的文献时，实际上，思考挑战我们的行为，而不是挑战性的行为。所以不是人，而是行为在挑战我们。当我刚开始学习这个时，我真的很喜欢他的想法。
and whether people start to develop signs of dementia, that really does impact on families as well as the person. So that idea of helping people see the dementia or the cognitive changes as something separate really can be so powerfully important. And it reminds me of when I was, Graham Stokes, literature actually, thinking about behaviour that challenges us, not challenging behaviour. So it's not the person, it's the behaviour that's challenging us. And I used to really like his ideas when
是的，这真的很重要，不是吗？是的。非常感谢。好了，让我们听听我们今天第四位也是最后一位临床心理学家的发言。最后但同样重要的是，波莉。嗨，很高兴能来到这里，分享这些关于老年人、老龄化和叙事疗法的重要想法。所以非常感谢这个机会。我叫波莉·凯泽。我已经从NHS退休了，
I was first starting learning about this. And yeah, it's just, it's really important stuff, isn't it? Yeah. Thank you so much. Right. Let's hear a little bit from our fourth and final clinical psychologist of the day. Last but not least, Polly. Hi, it's a real pleasure to be here and share these important ideas about older people, ageing and narrative therapy. So thank you so much for this opportunity. My name's Polly Kaiser. I've retired from the NHS,
但我仍在工作，举办工作坊、教学、写作，并且我参与了大曼彻斯特一个名为“成熟思想很重要”的生活经验小组，并与他们一起做关于诗歌和悲伤的创意项目。这就是我目前正在做的事情。我通过我正在做的一项关于悲伤的工作接触到了叙事疗法的想法，对象是一位失去了儿子的老年妇女。嗯，她是因为焦虑被转诊的。那是转诊原因。我看到这个是因为焦虑。然后我们追溯到这样一个事实，即她感到焦虑时，实际上是她儿子去世的周年纪念日，年龄日期。然后我们追溯到实际上他是一个双胞胎，而双胞胎在出生时就去世了，这个女人从来没有把她的悲伤关在一个黑暗的壁橱里，
but I'm still working, running workshops, teaching, writing, and I'm involved with a lived experience group in Greater Manchester called Mature Minds Matters and doing creative projects around poetry and grief with them. So that's what I'm currently doing. I got into the ideas of narrative therapy through some work I was doing on grief with an older woman who had lost her son. Well, she was referred for anxiety. That was the referral. I see this one for anxiety. And then we traced it back to the fact that she was anxious, when she was anxious was actually the anniversary of her son's death, age date. And then we traced back that actually he was a twin and the twin. died at birth and this woman had never had shut the her grief in a dark closet didn't
没有和家人谈论他，没有照片，什么都没有，即使理论说我应该帮助她做最后的告别，我也做不到，做不到。所以我和她的谈话是关于回忆、交谈，到最后，她在壁炉架上放了一张他的照片，他的兄弟姐妹可以谈论他，她也被纳入了家庭的一部分。现在，在不知不觉中，我已经做了一些回忆练习。所以当我遇到休·福克斯时，他在我在佩南加雷工作时监督我，他给了我迈克尔·怀特的开创性著作《再次问好》，就像罗莎琳说的灯泡一样，就像，叮，就是这个。就是这个。我可以，我可以
talk about him to the rest of the family no photos no nothing and even though the theory said I should help us say her final goodbye I couldn't do that couldn't do that so my conversations with her were about remembering talking and and by the end she had a photo of him on a mantelpiece and the red his siblings could talk about him and she was incorporated as part of the family. Now, without knowing it, I had done some remembering practices. So when I met Hugh Fox, who supervised me when I was working in Penangare, and he gave me Michael White's seminal book saying hello again, he was like, like, like, like, Roslyn said with a light bulb, it's like, bing, this is it. This is it. I can, I can
进行这种对话。我想我也受到了约翰·肖特在大学的教学、肯·格根、那些结构主义者的影响，有点像罗莎琳，我知道那个理论，也知道我的价值观，但我如何将其转化为我客户面前的治疗语言？所以迈克尔·怀特关于谈论悲伤和问好，以及如果那个人在这里，他们会重视什么，他们会如何看待你，你如何将他们纳入其中的建议。然后洛林·海德克关于回忆的折纸的想法真的触动了我关于失落的观点，并帮助我随后与老年人一起处理失落，不仅仅是死亡，还有其他失落，这，是的，那是一种很棒的工作，你知道，真的激发了你的
have this kind of conversation. And I guess I was also influenced by the teaching of John Schottor at university, Ken Gergen, those structuralists and a bit like Roslyn, I knew that theory and I knew my values, but how do I translate that into therapy speak in the room in front of my client? And so Michael White's suggestions around talking about grief and saying hello and if the person was here, what would they value, how would they see you, how do you incorporate them? And then Lorraine Heideker's ideas about the origami of remembering really spoke to me about loss and helped me then work alongside older people around loss, not just death, but other losses as well, which is, yeah, that's kind of a wonderful piece of work and, you know, really wet your
胃口，是的，让你渴望学习更多，并在你不是偶然的情况下，当你真正有目的地去做时，在临床上产生更大的影响。是的，我的意思是，我丈夫说，哦，你为什么要参加这个课程，因为你已经在做了。但我认为拥有那种语言，拥有那个社区，拥有那个支持社区，我们都对此感到饥渴。你知道，所以我们与伊丽莎白和罗莎琳的联系，就像，哦，还有别人，还有别人在那里。这本书感觉就像回家一样。感觉就像，哦，天哪，我真希望我早点有这本书。我希望这本书能与临床医生对话，有点像休的文章
appetite and, yeah, gave you thirst for learning more and being even more clinically impactful when you weren't being accidental, right, when you were being really purposeful about it. Yeah, I mean, my husband said, oh, why are you doing this? course because you're already doing it. But I think it's having that language and having that community and having that community of support and we're all hungry for it. You know, so our connections with Elizabeth and Roslin, it's like, oh, someone else, someone else like there. And the book feels like a coming home. It feels like a, oh, God, I wish I'd had this. And I'm hoping that this book speaks to clinicians out there, a bit like Hughes article
与我们对话，因为它也充满了实用的想法。不仅仅是关于客户，还关于与员工合作、在社区环境中工作、创造性地工作。所以，是的。告诉我们书名，波莉。嗨，是的，是《叙事疗法与老年人：挑战污名、支持联系和建立希望》。多可爱啊。封面很漂亮。
spoke to us because it's full of practical ideas as well. not just about clients, but about working with staff, working in community settings, working creatively. So, yeah. Tell us the name of the book, Polly. Hi, yeah, it's narrative therapy and older people. Challenging stigma, supporting connection and building hope. How lovely. It's very nice cover.
好的，谢谢。我们稍后会详细讨论这一点，但我意识到我们作为四位母语都是英语的白人女性。我们显然可以谈论这是我们的经历，但我们如何能够支持那些在成长过程中可能有不同经历，并且母语可能不是英语的人使用叙事疗法？我不知道谁想谈谈这一点。
Okay, thank you. We will talk more about that in a moment, but I'm aware that we are, as four white women who all our first languages are English. And we obviously can speak to that being our experience, but how might we be able to support people who might have had different experiences growing up and maybe whose language isn't English using narrative therapy? And I don't know who fancy speaking on that point.
我知道伊丽莎白和罗莎琳对此也有想法，但我首先想到的是我在罗奇代尔与一些南亚老年妇女合作，使用“生命之树”，帮助以一种安全和结构化的方式倾听她们关于创伤、移民和身份的故事，这样我们就可以审视她们的价值观、技能和希望。那种关于她们作为女性是谁，以及她们如何应对和在移民中幸存下来的基于资产的对话，提供了脚手架。这是一次对她们故事非常有帮助的庆祝。当时是在做生活故事工作的背景下。但当然，这不是一个……
I know Elizabeth and Roslin have got ideas about this as well, but the one that comes to my mind first was me working with some South Asian elder women in Rochdale using Tree of Life and helping to hear their stories of trauma and migration and identity, but in a safe and structured way so that we could look at their values and look at their skills and look at their hopes. And that scaffolded, that asset-based conversation about who they were as women and how they had. coped and survived with that migration. And it was a really helpful celebration of their stories. It was in the context of doing life story work at the time. But certainly it wasn't a depra...
虽然她们谈论了创伤性的事情，但这并不是一次创伤性的会议，因为它建立在她们的技能和能力之上。所以“生命之树”真的很有帮助。这让我想起与我合作过的几位客户做类似的事情，他们本质上是非法来到英国的，并有各种不同的路线来到这里，关于为什么这会发生在他们身上，他们是谁的故事的一部分，他们确实寻求了庇护，现在他们有了无限期居留权。但能够听到那个故事，并谈论他们对那个故事的理解，以及是什么促使他们做出了最终成为他们故事一部分的决定，这真是一种荣幸，是的，就像非常强大且重要的工作，我们帮助人们讲述他们自己的故事，是的，但不仅仅是这样，还要在此时此地理解他们的身份，以及他们拥有什么技能和资产，还有他们的韧性。罗莎琳，你想补充点什么吗？我只是在思考我们在叙事疗法中对语言和好奇心所赋予的重要性。所以有办法，我们会明确谈论来自那些不同的经历和视角，并邀请，你知道，并表达对那一点的兴趣，并邀请人们帮助我们理解。但我们也把很多重点放在使用当事人的语言上。你会看到叙事治疗师做的一件事，这看起来可能与某些方法非常不同，那就是不断做笔记，因为捕捉那些人的词汇和短语真的很重要，这样你就可以在与当事人交谈时使用它们。我们经常会为人们写文档，作为捕捉我们所做工作的一种方式。所以我们用那个人的语言来做这件事真的很重要。所以很多都是真正协商出来的
Although they talked about traumatic things, it wasn't a traumatic session because it built on their skills and their abilities. So Tree of Life was really helpful. It reminds me of doing something similar with a couple of clients I've worked with who had come to Britain illegally in essence and had various different routes here and kind of part of their stories about why that had happened to them, who then they did seek asylum and they have indefinite leave to remain now. But it's a real privilege to be able to hear that story and to talk about the sense they've
以一种非常透明的方式。我会说这是一种根本。那些关于差异和看待世界的方式不止一种的想法，对于这种方法来说是如此根本，以至于我认为这是一种与说其他语言的人一起使用的非常有帮助的方法，或者有许多关于通过口译员等使用叙事疗法的可爱文献例子。
made of that and what contributed to them making those decisions that then ultimately became part of their story and yeah like wonderfully powerfully important work where we where we help people tell their tale of themselves yeah but not just but also making sense of their identities in the here and now and what skills and assets they they have and their resilience as well rosalind would you like to add something i was just thinking about the importance we put on language and curiosity and narrative therapy. So there are ways to, we'd be explicitly talking about coming from those different experiences and perspectives and, and invite, you know, and expressing interest in that and inviting people to help us understand. But we also put a lot of emphasis on using the language
非常感谢，罗莎琳。伊丽莎白。是的，谢谢。我只是想补充一点，许多叙事疗法实践已经在世界各地的许多不同文化中得到了发展。所以这方面有很多分享。特别是大卫·丹弗关于集体叙事实践的工作，涵盖了卢旺达种族灭绝后所做的大量工作、在巴勒斯坦的工作以及各种不同的文化。所以我认为与其他许多治疗模式相比，叙事疗法已经在各种各样的不同文化中得到了发展，并且想法也得到了分享。特别是，例如，“生命之树”是在南部非洲开发的，它使用了
of the person. And one thing you'd see a narrative therapist doing which can look quite different to what approach is, is constantly taking notes because it's really important to capture those person's words and phrases so that you can be using them back with the person. and we'd often be writing, making documents for people as a way to capture the work we've done. So it's really important we're doing that in that person's language. So a lot of that is really negotiated
树的隐喻，这是一个世界许多地方都有树的隐喻，所以它可以以那种方式应用。而且它对文化非常适应。所以你进行作为其一部分的庆祝活动的方式，你画树的方式，可能会根据你所在地方的树木种类而看起来非常不同。所以我认为这就是叙事疗法真正令人兴奋的地方，它借鉴了许多不同的文化
in a very transparent way. I would say it's kind of fundamental. Those ideas of difference and not being one way to see the world are so fundamental to the approach that I think it's a really helpful approach to be using with people who speak other languages or with, there's lots of lovely literature around, examples of working through interpreters and so on with narrative therapy.
并且可以应用于许多不同的文化和许多不同的人群。非常感谢。我正在听你们所有人说话，我在想，如果有人在服务机构工作，也许是在NHS服务机构，他们必须证明他们有循证实践，并且，你知道，遵循NICE指南，叙事疗法是以这种方式呈现的吗？这是否可以在监督中进行辩论？好吧，让我们这样做，因为实际上它有很好的成功率。因为人们可能会说，是的，我喜欢那个想法，但我需要让，你知道，我服务机构里的人觉得这很棒。这是一个好主意。罗莎琳，你对此有什么想法吗？这是我们经常讨论的事情，因为我们非常清楚我们需要为我们正在做的事情以及原因做出说明。叙事作为一种方法，你可能听得出来，它不是一种你可以手册化或作为典型RCT（随机对照试验）运行的方法。所以这与系统性方法在这一点上会挣扎是一样的。但我们真正
Thank you so much, Roslyn. Elizabeth. Yes, thank you. I just wanted to add that a lot of narrative therapy practices have been developed in lots of different cultures around the world. So there's quite a sharing of that. So particularly David Denver's work on collective narrative practices, covers quite a lot of work that was done in Rwanda, following the genocide there, work in Palestine, and all sorts of different cultures. So I think compared to many other therapy models, narrative therapy has been developed and ideas have been shared across quite a very wide variety of different cultures. And particularly, for example, Tree of Life was developed in Southern Africa and that was using the
感兴趣的是获得那种定性反馈以及与我们合作的人进行评估的方法，并且有一些有趣的，你知道，我们正在就其他可能有助于捕捉这项工作及其价值的方法论进行对话，所以据我所知，你不会在NICE指南中找到它，至少在老年人方面，你不会。在威尔士，我们有叫Matrix Cymory的东西，它在其中被引用，但在它没有那种传统证据基础的背景下。但这实际上是我们写这本书的驱动力，思考我们如何开始分享所有这些我们发现这非常有帮助的方式的故事？
metaphor of a tree, which is a metaphor that many parts of the world have got trees, so it can can kind of be applied in that way. And it's very adaptable to the culture. So the way that you might do celebrations that are part of it, the way that you might draw your trees might look very different depending on what kind of trees you have where you are. So I think that's what's really exciting about narrative therapy is that way that it draws on lots of different cultures
所以我们的书是这样写的，很多作者都是接受过这种方法并一直在说的人，有一个叫维夫的女士和我一起写了其中的一部分，关于在患有痴呆症且在早期生活中经历过创伤的人的背景下使用这种方法。她坚持认为，必须写出来给人们希望。她从没想过会有希望，她发现这种方法对她有效。所以她想让很多其他人知道它。所以这当然是动机，但我们非常参与并思考我们还有什么其他方式来评估这一点。
and can be applied to lots of different cultures and lots of different groups of people as well. Thank you so much. I'm just listening to you all speak and I'm thinking if someone's working in a service, maybe in an NHS service, and they're having to demonstrate they've got evidence-based practice and, you know, following nice guidance, is narrative therapy represented in that way? And is that something that could kind of be argued at supervision? Well, let's do this because actually it's got this really good success rating. Like, because people might be right, yeah, I'd love that idea, but I need to get, you know, the people in my service to have great. this is a great idea. Roslyn, have you got any ideas on that one? This is something we have lots of conversations about because we are well aware that we need to be making the case for what we're doing and why. Narrative, as an approach, you can probably hear that it's not approach you can manualise or run as a kind of typical RCT. So that's in the same way, though, that systemic approaches would struggle with that. But what we're really
因为它是非常新的，与痴呆症患者甚至老年人的心理疗法，相对于其他客户群体来说仍然相当新。所以那个证据基础仍然在出现。我们仍然非常努力地写那个。我可以看到波莉迫不及待地想说点什么，所以我打算传给她。继续，我知道在结果方面还有很多工作要做
interesting as getting that qualitative feedback and ways evaluating with the people we're working with and there's some interesting you know we're having conversations about other types of methodologies that might help capture capture this work and its value so you won't find it in nice guidance as far as I'm aware at least I've older people you don't in Wales we've something called Matrix Cymory and it is referenced within that but in the context of it not having that traditional evidence base But that was very much the driving force for us writing this book, actually, was thinking, how do we start sharing all these stories of ways in which we found this to be really helpful?
我们一直在与研究人员交谈。但在做生活故事工作的背景下，这是由叙事实践所告知的，我记得去过痴呆症中心。他说，哦，不，不，你不能在进行RCT之前将其引入NHS。但实际上人们自己喜欢做它。他们想做它。
And so our book is written that a lot of the authors are people have lived experience who've received this approach and have been saying there's a lady called Viv who wrote a section of it with me about using this in a context of someone with dementia who's experienced trauma in earlier life. And she was adamant, this had to be written to give people hope. She never thought there could be hope and she's found this approach has worked for her. And so she wanted lots of other people to know about it. So that was certainly the motivation, but something we're very much engaging with them thinking about how else do we to evaluate this.
它成为了一场运动，并被写入了痴呆症委托指南和其他指南中。所以实际上它成为了一种客户实践，人们不是像鲍勃·伍兹和其他研究人员那样研究人们，但它不需要那个RCT就能把它摆上台面，我认为叙事疗法通常处于类似的位置，像维夫、凯伦、基思和克里斯这样的人，你知道，我们书中的生活经验丰富的人真的很重视它
Because it's very new, psychological therapies with people in dementia and even with older people, is still fairly new relative to with other client groups. And so that evidence base is still emerging. We're still very much trying to write that. I can see Polly's desperate to say something, so I'm going to pass it. Go ahead, I know there's still loads to do on outcomes
而且我知道从委托人那里，他们真的很重视那些故事，那些故事像RCT试验一样触动了委托人的心，所以我鼓励人们真正利用故事的力量。谢谢。我喜欢故事。和案例研究，以及了解事情在现实生活中如何为人们呈现。这让我想起当我还是助理心理学家时，那是很久以前的事了。我当时在三个病房的住院环境中工作。其中两个病房有被诊断为痴呆症的人。我们发现的是，员工只是无法真正想象
and we're talking with researchers all the time. But in the context of doing the life story work, which is informed by narrative practice, I remember going to the dementia cz. And he said, oh, no, no, you can't introduce it into NHS until you've had an RCT. But actually people themselves liked doing it. They wanted to do it.
这个人以前会是什么样子。我知道在文献中，当时人们普遍将痴呆症患者称为可能一直有点，你知道，有点古怪或有点，你知道，不寻常，或者他们可能一直喜欢走来走去，或者可能一直有点紧张或健忘。实际上，当我们做生活故事工作并能够与病房工作人员分享时，实际上这个人过去在影响力很大的行业工作，过着完全积极的生活，喜欢做父母。喜欢被，你知道，为你而在，会一直记得你的生日，
It became a movement and it became written into commissioning guidance for the dementia commissioning guidance and in other guidance. So that actually it became a customer practice that people are not researching people like Bob Woods and other researchers, but it didn't need that RCT just to get it on the table and I think narrative therapy generally is in that similar position where people like Viv and Karen and Keith and Chris you know that the people with lived experience in our book really value it
并且会给你寄一些非常特别的东西，会为你烤这些不可思议的东西，并且，你知道，喜欢做祖父母，或者是一个令人惊叹的同事支持来源，并且仍然被非常亲切地谈论。它赋予了员工权力，然后，我想，能够看到那个人，而不仅仅是诊断。当然，当然。而且我认为对我来说，痴呆症是我们职业生涯中看到变化的社会话语之一。我当然有，从，你知道，文化话语非常多是长期住院，非常困难，非常具有挑战性，正如你提到的格雷厄姆·斯托克的东西。它已经从那样变成了像基思和，你知道，痴呆症日记作者和伊丽莎白合作的人，他们比我更能谈论，他们声称那个空间与痴呆症一起生活得很好。所以痴呆症的叙事和社会建构也正在改变，多亏了这些痴呆症活动家以及像伊丽莎白和罗莎琳目前与痴呆症患者所做的工作。
and and I know from commissioners they really value those stories and those stories speak to the hearts of commissioners as much as our CT trials do so I would encourage people to really use the power of stories. Thank you. I love stories. and case studies and learning about how things show up for people in real life. And it's reminding me of when I was an assistant psychologist, so quite a while ago now. And I was working in an inpatient setting across three wards. And two of the wards had people with dementia diagnoses on them. And what we were finding is that the staff just couldn't really imagine
谢谢。如果有人正在听这个或看这个，他们可能处于职业生涯的任何阶段，对吧？所以他们可能是职业生涯早期。他们可能是，你知道，已经确定的合格临床医生。开始了解这个并将其带入监督和与人实践总是可以的吗，你会这么说吗？永远不会太晚。学习永远不会太晚。
what this person would have been like before. And I know in the literature it was common at that time for people to refer to people with dementia as probably always having been a bit, you know, a bit quirky or a bit, you know, unusual or that they maybe always liked to walk about a lot or maybe were always a bit jittery or forgetful. And actually, when we were doing life story work and we're able to share with the ward staff, actually this person used to work in really high impact industry and had full active lives, love being a parent. loved being, you know, there for you, would remember your birthday all the time,
也许也永远不会太早。我还在学习。我还在阅读。我还在学习。我在退休前不久还在学习EMDR。我没有在实践它，但我需要更多地了解它。我会鼓励其他人买我们的书
and would send you something really special and would bake you these incredible things and, you know, love being a grandparent or was an amazing source of support for colleagues and is still spoken about really fondly. It empowered the staff to then, I guess, be able to see that person, not just the diagnosis. Sure, sure. And I think to me, Dementia is one of those social discourses that we've seen change in our careers. I certainly have from, you know, the cultural discourse was very much long stay, very difficult, very challenging as you brought up the day of the Graham Stoke stuff. And it's gone from that to people like Keith and, you know, the dementia diarists and people that Elizabeth works with and can speak to more than I can, who've claimed that space living well with dementia. So the narrative and the social construct of dementia is also changing thanks to these dementia activists and the work that people like Elizabeth and Roslin currently do with people with dementia.
并思考、学习和了解更多关于叙事疗法的信息。因为它也有助于减轻员工倦怠。因为我们都带着激励我们在NHS工作的价值观而来。这种方法非常符合临床医生的价值观。我想伊丽莎白对此有话要说，或者无论如何还有别的话。是的，我正要进来谈谈关于进入叙事疗法永远不会太早或太晚。
Thank you. And if someone's listening to this or watching this, they could be at any stage of their career, right? So they might be early career. They might be, you know, established qualified clinicians already. is it always okay to start kind of learning about this and bringing this to supervision and to practice with people, would you say? Never too late. Never too late to learn.
而且我认为关于它如何符合价值观有一些东西，所以我认为这对早期职业心理学家来说特别重要，是关于审视不同类型的疗法并思考什么对你重要，你喜欢什么样的模型，什么符合你的经验，因为这就是一些证据基础，不是吗？当治疗师使用感觉适合他们的模型时，他们可以对人们更有帮助，我真的很喜欢叙事疗法的这一点，它符合价值观。我在成为心理学家之前很久就喜欢故事和听老年人交谈。而且我认为有很多不同的方法。我正要思考
And never too early maybe as well. I'm still learning. I'm still reading. I'm still learning. I was learning about EMDR just before I retired. I'm not practicing in it, but I needed to know more about it. And I would encourage other people to buy our book
生命之树。这特别有助于将人们聚集在一起，这是对我来说很重要的另一个价值观，实际上我们知道孤立真的很重要，导致了心理健康困难。所以叙事疗法也有集体方法。关于将人们聚集在一起。所以我为患有痴呆症的人举办了生命之树小组。当我把他们聚集在一起，我们听到他们的个人故事，我们听到他们是如何联系的，这真的让我很着迷。
and think and learn and know more about narrative therapy. because it also helps mitigate against staff burnout. And because we all come with values that motivate us to work in the NHS. And this approach really fits clinicians' values. I think Elizabeth's got something to say about that, or something else anyway. Yeah, I was just going to come in there about it's never too early or too late to get into narrative therapy.
并思考、学习和了解更多关于叙事疗法的知识。因为它也有助于缓解员工的职业倦怠。而且我们每个人都怀揣着激励我们在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作的价值观。这种方法确实符合临床医生的价值观。我想伊丽莎白对此有什么想说的，或者其他什么。是的，我正想说，接触叙事疗法永远不会太早或太晚。
And I think there's something about how it fits with values so I think that's something particularly for for early career psychologists is about looking at the different types of therapy and thinking what matters to you what kind of model do you like what fits to your experience and because that's some of the evidence base isn't it that when when therapists use models that feel like a fit for them then they can be more helpful to people and I really like that about narrative therapy that it fit with the values. I like stories and listening to older people talk long before I got into to being a psychologist. And I think there are lots of the different approaches. I was going to think about
我认为它与价值观的契合度很高，所以对于职业生涯早期的心理学家来说，重要的是审视不同类型的疗法，思考什么对你重要，你喜欢什么样的模式，什么适合你的经验。因为证据基础也表明，当治疗师使用适合自己的模式时，他们能更好地帮助他人。我非常喜欢叙事疗法的一点就是它与价值观的契合。早在成为心理学家之前，我就喜欢故事，喜欢听老年人交谈。我想有很多不同的方法。我当时在想
tree of life. That particularly helps bring people together, which is another value that's important to me, that actually we know that isolation is really important, contributed to mental health difficulties. And so narrative therapy also has collective approaches. about bringing people together. So I ran Tree of Life groups for people living with dementia. And what really intrigued me when we brought them together and we heard their individual stories and we heard how they connected.
生命之树。它特别有助于将人们聚集在一起，这也是对我而言很重要的另一个价值观，因为我们确实知道孤立感非常重要，它会导致心理健康问题。因此，叙事疗法也有关于将人们聚集在一起的集体方法。所以我为痴呆症患者举办了生命之树小组。当我们将他们聚集在一起，听到他们个人的故事，并听到他们是如何建立联系时，我感到非常着迷。
And when I asked them about the storms, the sort of troubles in life that they all talked about the stigma. They talked about how they were spoken to in a different way, how they were stroked and patted in ways that nobody ever did this before. You know, these are people who did a whole range of jobs and backgrounds. Yeah, so they were talking about the ways they were being patronised and treated differently because of their diagnosis, not because not on the basis of what they could and couldn't do
当我问起他们关于风暴，也就是他们所谈论的生活中的种种困境时，他们提到了耻辱感。他们谈到别人与他们交谈的方式发生了变化，他们被以一种前所未有的方式抚摸和轻拍。要知道，这些人来自各行各业，背景各异。是的，他们谈论的是因为他们的诊断结果而受到屈尊俯就和区别对待，而不是基于他们能做什么或不能做什么。
and how they could and couldn't contribute. And so that's also why we've also done a lot of projects around creative arts and bringing in things like poetry. So Asisha Mojaria, Kavarra, Val did a project where we had took people from our post-diagnostic course, so they just had dementia, they came along to learn about dementia. She got them to read some poetry written by people with dementia and then write their own words, which were then putting together into a collective group poem. That was then passed to the next course that was run in that town and then their
以及他们能或不能做出什么贡献。这也是为什么我们围绕创意艺术开展了许多项目，并引入了诗歌等元素。Asisha Mojaria、Kavarra 和 Val 做了一个项目，我们邀请了参加我们诊断后课程的人，他们刚被诊断出患有痴呆症，来学习相关知识。她让他们阅读一些由痴呆症患者创作的诗歌，然后写下自己的文字，再将这些文字汇编成一首集体诗。这首诗随后被传给该镇举办的下一期课程，然后他们的
response was then passed to the next course. And so that way you got that really tackled that stigma, So the people with dementia realized that they were one of not just the eight or ten on the course, but the sort of 30, 40, 50, you know, as the months went on. And I thought that was a really fabulous way of kind of linking lives. And I know that we've done a number of arts projects around photography, poetry, screenwriting and things like that. That's wonderful. And so nice to really think actually it's not just me. You know, other people have this as well, Polly.
回应又被传给下一期课程。通过这种方式，我们真正解决了耻辱感的问题，让痴呆症患者意识到，他们不仅是课程中的八九个人，而是随着时间的推移，有三四十甚至五十个人。我认为这是一种将人们的生活联系起来的绝妙方式。我知道我们已经开展了许多关于摄影、诗歌、剧本创作等方面的艺术项目。这太棒了。能让人真正意识到“其实不只是我一个人”，这感觉真好，Polly。
Yeah, just to say about the poetry with the dementia, we also use poetry as a vehicle with mature minds matters to help reduce stigma again, whether they read poems about mental health, and they wrote all their own poems that are collected in rhymes from the wise, and people's voices are on there, speaking their poems. So I think in terms of that, and we did outside a witness, a definitional ceremony to capture people's stories.
是的，关于痴呆症诗歌，我们还利用诗歌作为“成熟心灵很重要”（Mature Minds Matters）项目的载体，再次帮助减少耻辱感。他们阅读关于心理健康的诗歌，并写下自己的诗，这些诗被收录在《智者的韵律》（Rhymes from the Wise）中，人们的声音也被录制下来，朗诵着他们的诗作。我认为就这一点而言，我们还在外部见证了一场定义仪式，以捕捉人们的故事。
That's a practice we haven't really spoken about, but it's very powerful way to listen to people's stories and have them witnessed. And I think that's another tool to use with commissioners as well to structure storytelling and story listening. Yeah. Thank you. And obviously if we're thinking about this
这是一种我们还没怎么讨论过的做法，但它是一种倾听人们故事并让其得到见证的非常有力的方式。我认为这也是与委托人合作的另一个工具，可以用来构建讲故事和倾听故事的框架。是的，谢谢。显然，如果我们从
from a bottom up perspective, so because there isn't like huge amounts of conversations out there at the moment about narrative therapy, we might be attracting people people who are thinking, maybe this might work for me to help me work through this problem I'm having or this difficulty or this thing I keep coming up against. And I know it's how long is a piece of string, but if someone is watching or listening for this reason, how, you know, what might they be struggling with that they could really respond well to, Polly?
自下而上的角度来思考，因为目前关于叙事疗法的对话还不是很多，我们可能会吸引那些认为“也许这能帮我解决我正面临的问题、困难或我不断遇到的障碍”的人。我知道这很难一概而论，但如果有人因为这个原因在观看或收听，他们可能会在哪些方面遇到困难，而叙事疗法又能很好地回应他们呢，Polly？
I've got two examples. I'll be quick, sorry, Liz. One is we had floods a few years ago, boxing day floods and I worked alongside a woman who was an amazing powerhouse getting flood relief and sharit and clearing houses and I was struggling to write and she was struggling in her marriage at the time and so I used tree of life with her to help her think about her marriage and she did end up leaving her husband and is now happily remarried but you know that was just an everyday incident I've also used it with my kids and with people that I know just about where are they now in their lives and what are their hopes for the future? And I've used it, you know, in myself about where am I and what are my hopes.
我有两个例子。抱歉，Liz，我会长话短说。一个是几年前我们遭遇了洪水，节礼日洪水，我和一位女性一起工作，她是一位了不起的实干家，负责救灾、分发物资和清理房屋。当时我正为写作而苦恼，而她正为婚姻问题而挣扎，所以我用“生命之树”帮助她思考自己的婚姻。她最终确实离开了丈夫，现在又幸福地再婚了。但你知道，那只是一个日常事件。我也曾把它用在我的孩子和我认识的人身上，关于他们现在的生活处于什么阶段，对未来有什么希望？我也曾用它来审视自己，我在哪里，我的希望是什么。
So I think, you know, just as a reflective tool for myself, reflective tools for friends and family, it's been in everyday circumstances, it's been really helpful. So nice. Thank you, Elizabeth. Yeah, we've used Tree of Life and Narrative Practices associated with that with assistant psychologists. around the time of not getting on to clinical training to really help people think through their values and that which people have found quite helpful we've also used it quite a lot at the end of placement so when undergraduates or nursing students and that's been great because we've used people living with dementia to come and co-facilitate with us and and help students think through
所以我认为，作为一种自我反思工具，以及为朋友和家人提供的反思工具，它在日常生活中非常有帮助。太好了。谢谢你，Elizabeth。是的，我们曾与助理心理学家一起使用“生命之树”和相关的叙事实践，在他们未能进入临床培训期间，帮助人们深入思考自己的价值观，这被证明非常有帮助。我们还在实习结束时经常使用它，当本科生或护理专业的学生实习结束时，这非常棒，因为我们邀请了痴呆症患者与我们共同引导，并帮助学生思考
you know what matters to them as they're moving on to qualify or whatever it can be really helpful from that point of view. I'd also like to recommend retelling the stories of our lives by David Dembra. That's kind of a book written kind of as a self-help book or for therapists, but it's got a lot of exercises that people might find helpful to kind of, they want to start thinking about narrative therapy in relation to themselves. And I think that's one of its strengths as a therapy, is it's really useful for us as therapists to help us stay connected to why we want to do this work.
你知道，当他们即将获得资格或面临其他选择时，什么对他们来说是重要的，从这个角度来看，这真的很有帮助。我还想推荐 David Denborough 的《重述我们生命的故事》（Retelling the Stories of Our Lives）。这是一本既可以作为自助书，也可以供治疗师参考的书，但它包含许多练习，如果人们想开始思考叙事疗法与自身的关系，可能会觉得很有帮助。我认为这是它作为一种疗法的优势之一，它对我们治疗师来说非常有用，能帮助我们保持与从事这项工作的初衷的联系。
So it's really useful in supervision. It's really useful in staff away days. It's useful in helping staff teams bring together reports to management, as one of our colleagues wrote about in the book. So lots and lots of ways it can be used both for us and for individuals. Thank you so much. Now let's talk about your book before we finish. Polly, I know you've got a copy in front of you.
所以它在督导中非常有用。在员工休息日也非常有用。它有助于员工团队向管理层提交报告，正如我们的一位同事在书中写到的那样。所以它有很多很多种用途，既适用于我们，也适用于个人。非常感谢。现在在我们结束之前，让我们谈谈你们的书。Polly，我知道你面前有一本。
So why don't you tell us about your book? I was really proud. honoured that Roslyn and Elizabeth invited me to join them on the editorial team for this book. It's a book I enjoyed writing. I enjoyed the colleagues, the other authors. I've enjoyed learning, re-learning. There's really accessible ideas and tools and it's just very, very rich and I think it would help. And it's also got a chapter on aging as a therapist, which I contributed to at the end with a colleague in New Zealand, Diane. And I think we don't talk enough about ourselves as aging as, you know, sort of retired from the NHS, what's the impact of
那么，为什么不给我们介绍一下你的书呢？我感到非常自豪和荣幸，Roslyn 和 Elizabeth 邀请我加入这本书的编辑团队。这是一本我写得很开心的书。我很喜欢我的同事和其他作者。我享受学习和重新学习的过程。书中有非常易懂的理念和工具，内容非常丰富，我认为它会有所帮助。书中还有一章关于“作为治疗师的老龄化”，这是我在最后与新西兰的同事 Diane 共同撰写的。我认为我们对自己作为老龄化的人，比如从 NHS 退休后的影响，谈论得还不够多。
aging ourselves? So it's quite a reflective piece. So in terms of what career stage, if people are at end of career stage, I'd invite them to have a look at that. But I think Roslyn, it was the brainchild of Rosalind, so I'll invite Rosalind to actually explain it in more detail. I guess because I was in this position that we kind of referred to earlier around feeling I needed to justify why I'm doing the work we're doing, but also, feeling very motivated to start thinking, how do we get the word out there more? And so I'd had some conversations with Elizabeth about this.
我们自己变老了？所以这是一篇相当具有反思性的文章。因此，就职业阶段而言，如果人们处于职业生涯末期，我会邀请他们看看那一章。但我认为 Roslyn，这是 Rosalind 的心血结晶，所以我邀请 Rosalind 来详细解释一下。我想是因为我处于我们之前提到的那种境地，觉得需要证明我为什么要做我们正在做的工作，但也非常有动力开始思考，我们如何才能让更多人了解它？所以我曾与 Elizabeth 就此进行过一些交谈。
And just we got the older adult psychologists who we've met in various narrative therapy trainings together to start thinking through this together. And Polly was kind of an experienced colleague who'd done another book, so it was a good kind of brain to pick from. But it's very much a collaborative effort, it's very much written, we hope,
我们把在各种叙事疗法培训中遇到的老年心理学家聚在一起，开始共同思考这个问题。Polly 是一位经验丰富的同事，她写过另一本书，所以她是一个很好的请教对象。但这确实是一项协作努力，我们希望它是
in the spirit of the approach itself. so that every chapter is co-written. We have the voices of people we've lived experience, as we've mentioned. We've been here too, as well as other practitioners who we've worked with from other disciplines and from the voluntary sector. So it's very rich in terms of the multiple voices and perspectives.
以这种方法本身的精神写成的。每一章都是共同撰写的。正如我们提到的，我们有具有生活经验的人的声音。我们也有其他我们合作过的来自其他学科和志愿部门的从业者的声音。因此，就多种声音和视角而言，它非常丰富。
And it takes you through. We start the first couple of chapters are very much introducing and explaining more about what narrative therapy is and some of the theoretical principles and references, but there's then chapters on specific areas like working with loss, like working with trauma being another one, about the experience of being a dementia caregiver's one.
它会引导你阅读。前几章主要是介绍和解释什么是叙事疗法，以及一些理论原则和参考资料，但随后有关于特定领域的章节，比如处理失落，处理创伤是另一章，关于痴呆症护理人员的经历也是一章。
And we move into the lovely chapter out of therapy and into life, which Elizabeth led on, which is more around community-based practices, as well as thinking about aging as therapists. So we try and, we hope to capture the kind of diversity of ways we can work with narrative therapy. And we've really written it as a way to try and be accessible for anyone so we hope it would be useful for clinicians with lots of ideas in there and or academic psychologists perhaps but also for older people themselves to understand often older
我们进入了精彩的章节“走出治疗，走进生活”，由 Elizabeth 主导，这更多是关于社区实践，以及思考作为治疗师的老龄化问题。所以我们尝试，我们希望捕捉到我们运用叙事疗法方式的多样性。我们写这本书是为了让任何人都能轻松阅读，所以我们希望它对临床医生有用，里面有很多想法，或者对学术心理学家也有用，但同时也为了让老年人自己理解，通常老年人
people come with all kinds of stigma about therapy not necessarily having been being exposed to the language of psychology in the way that younger generations have been and it's also about saying that there is hope there are things that can be different and these are some ideas so we've written in a way where the technical parts and theoretical parts in there for people who want that but we've tried to write in ways that those can also be skipped across for people where that would be less successful or of less interest with lots of stories in there as as polly's said so that that's the hope we hope it's um it's achieving achieving that for people but certainly like polly i it felt really a lovely privilege to write because it's such a
带着各种关于治疗的耻辱感，不一定像年轻一代那样接触过心理学术语。这也是为了说明，希望是存在的，事情是可以改变的，这些是一些想法。所以我们以一种方式编写，技术和理论部分供需要的人参考，但我们也尝试以一种方式编写，即对于那些觉得这些部分不太适用或兴趣不大的人，可以跳过这些部分，正如 Polly 所说，里面有很多故事。这就是我们的希望，我们希望它能实现这一目标。但当然，像 Polly 一样，我觉得写这本书是一种荣幸，因为它是一个
collective effort we had a lovely workshop in Manchester of quite few of the authors we had lots of ways of linking in with people as we went along. So it was a lot of fun. Oh, it sounds amazing. What a great resource. Just remind us of the title there, Rosalind. So I've also got one here to check. It's a long title. So narrative therapy and older people, challenging stigma, supporting connection and building hope. Thank you so much. And thank you so much for all of your time in speaking with us today. It's such an interesting topic. And I just and really keen for more people to get their ears and their eyes on this and start using this clinically with people to affect really lovely change.
集体努力，我们在曼彻斯特举办了一个很棒的研讨会，很多作者都参加了，我们在过程中有很多与人们联系的方式。所以这非常有趣。哦，听起来太棒了。真是个伟大的资源。提醒我们一下书名，Rosalind。我也拿了一本核对一下。书名很长。是《叙事疗法与老年人：挑战耻辱，支持连接，建立希望》。非常感谢。也非常感谢你们今天花时间与我们交谈。这是一个非常有趣的话题。我真的很渴望更多人能听到和看到这些内容，并开始在临床上与人们一起使用它，以产生非常美好的改变。
Thank you very much. Thank you so much. Thank you so much to my guests. Lovely to have you here. Thank you, Roslyn Offord and Polly Kaiser. If you'd like to check out their new book, there are details in the show notes or in the description. I would love to know what this episode has evoked for you.
非常感谢。非常感谢。非常感谢我的嘉宾。很高兴你们能来。谢谢 Roslyn Offord 和 Polly Kaiser。如果你想查看他们的新书，详细信息在节目说明或描述中。我很想知道这一集对你有什么触动。
Please do come and let us know on So, where you can tag me, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere, or you can comment on YouTube or ask a question or make a comment on Spotify. If you love the show, please do rate and review us on Apple Podcasts. It really does help the show to grow. And as we are newly getting comfortable in our brand new name of psychology actually, it would be great to get as many new listeners and viewers on this content as possible. Of course, if you've been here a while, you know the content hasn't changed. It's just the name. do like hearing about people's stories especially professional stories you might well find the clinical psychologist collective book and the aspiring psychologist collective book helpful which is all about people's experiences reflections and real life accounts to becoming qualified psychologists
请一定要来告诉我们，你可以在那里标记我，我到处都是 Dr. Marianne Trent，或者你可以在 YouTube 上评论，或者在 Spotify 上提问或发表评论。如果你喜欢这个节目，请在 Apple Podcasts 上给我们评分和评论。这真的有助于节目的成长。随着我们逐渐适应“心理学实际上”（Psychology Actually）这个新名字，如果能让尽可能多的新听众和观众看到这些内容就太好了。当然，如果你已经关注我们一段时间了，你知道内容没有变，只是名字变了。如果你喜欢听人们的故事，尤其是职业故事，你可能会发现《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）和《有抱负的心理学家集体》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）这两本书很有帮助，它们都是关于人们成为合格心理学家的经历、反思和真实记录。
all the books and resources we've mentioned in today's episode on narrative therapy will be featured in the show notes if you like receiving updates when episodes are available or you just like hearing from me Why not join my mailing list, which you can do by heading to my website, www.w. Aspiring-psychologist.co. If you really like being part of my world, you might well consider the aspiring psychologist membership. Or there's our subscriber, members-only content, podcast episodes called Inner Work. They really are lovely, thoughtful, reflective, like a kind of step behind the curtain on therapy,
今天节目中提到的所有关于叙事疗法的书籍和资源都将在节目说明中列出。如果你喜欢在剧集发布时收到更新，或者只是喜欢听我分享，何不加入我的邮件列表呢？你可以通过访问我的网站 www.aspiring-psychologist.co 来加入。如果你真的很喜欢成为我世界的一部分，你可能会考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”。或者还有我们的订阅者专属内容，名为“内在工作”（Inner Work）的播客剧集。它们真的很可爱、深思熟虑、富有反思性，就像是治疗幕后的一步，
little bits of my life, my experiences along the years, and I think you'll find it really inspiring. You can join on YouTube directly on Captivate or get a three-free day trial on Apple Podcasts. I really do love your ideas for episodes. So if you have got any suggestions for either yourself as a guest or someone you'd like me to chat with or something you'd like me to chat about, please do feel free to pitch me ideas for the show. Which you can do by contacting me on socials. LinkedIn is a really easy place to get hold of me. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent there. Hi, I'm Max and a worker's assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly
我生活中的点滴，我多年来的经历，我想你会发现它真的很鼓舞人心。你可以直接在 YouTube 上加入，在 Captivate 上加入，或者在 Apple Podcasts 上获得三天免费试用。我真的很喜欢你们对剧集的想法。所以如果你有任何建议，无论是关于你自己作为嘉宾，还是你想让我与之交谈的人，或者你想让我谈论的话题，请随时向我推销你的节目想法。你可以通过社交媒体联系我。LinkedIn 是一个很容易找到我的地方。我是 Dr. Marianne Trent。嗨，我是 Max，是西约克郡学习障碍服务部门的一名助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在慢慢但肯定地朝着那个看似
impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that angle in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marion's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills,
不可能的目标——进入临床博士课程而努力。考虑到这一点，我想看看有什么资源，看看哪些书对我有帮助。我偶然发现了 Marianne 的书《临床心理学家集体》，并决定这将是我旅程中的一次很棒的购买。我发现 Marion 的书非常翔实，非常有见地。我特别喜欢这些故事如何让我确信，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上完美，只要你有良好的人际交往能力，
such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all the spy, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
比如同情心和共情能力，你就能达到目标。我强烈向所有有抱负的心理学家推荐这本书，也向那些想更多了解临床心理学世界并希望有一天能在该领域工作的人推荐。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。